>>> Also more trouble, legal trouble potentially
for former president Donald Trump.
His attorney representing him in the justice
department's probe into classified documents
found at mar-a-lago took highly detailed notes
about their conversation, a particular note.
The former president wanted to push back against
the justice department's efforts to recover
those classified documents or at least asked
his lawyers if it would be possible to fight
that subpoena.
The notes are now from trump's lawyer, Evan
Corcoran, in the hands of special counsel
jack Smith.
Also, sources tell CNN prosecutors subpoenaed
the trump organization for information about
business deals with foreign companies, specifically
in countries that may have been interested
in the types of classified materials recovered
from the former president at mar-a-lago.
The trump organization has just released a
statement.
Let me read it to you in part, quote, we made
a strict pledge to not enter in any new foreign
deals while president trump was in office.
A commitment that the company
[7:11:33 AM]
A commitment that the company fully complied
with.
Joining us now, CNN political commentator
Errol Louis and Jeremy salon.
Good to have you both.
Jeremy, I'll start with you.
It's normal that an attorney, a good attorney,
Evan Corcoran, would take detailed notes.
How they got to the media is another question.
But the fact that jack Smith has them now
after such a fight to get to this point regardless,
how could this impact the investigation?
>> Well, on its face people can think or assume
that the president is just saying, hey, I
want to fight this.
This is a reasonable conversation to have.
>> It Mike, right?
We should give him that.
>> Certainly should, but at the same time,
that's a direct look into his intent and his
knowledge that these are documents that are
classified.
These are documents I have to return.
>> That I shouldn't have.
>> Correct.
But nonetheless, I'm going to find a way to
challenge it.
And there's legal means to do soon then there's
legal means to not do so.
It kind of defeats the argument that I didn't
know.
>> That's so interesting.
>> I wanted to ask about attorney/client privilege.
[7:12:33 AM]
attorney/client privilege.
I couldn't help myself the notes of one of
his attorneys was sort of in the hands of
jack Smith.
Can they use that if they deem, look, we got
these.
Can't say how.
But we have them?
>> You certainly raise it as a defense.
But as we know, attorney/client privileges
defeated if what is going on is an attempt
to either commit or obstruct the investigation
of a crime.
And in that case he's right back where he
started.
So, you know, what's really going to matter
is what else went on in that conversation.
It's one thing to learn that Donald Trump
asked can we sort of fight against the subpoena.
But what else was said?
What did the attorneys then tell him?
How did he react to that?
That's where it's going to start to get sticky,
I think.
>> That's really interesting.
>> It's interesting because that's the defense
Nixon tried to use and the supreme court said,
look, you can only do this to a certain point.
And when we're investigating a crime -- let's
turn the table here on what E. Jean Carroll
is trying to do after winning that sexual
battery and defense case against the former
president.
[7:13:33 AM]
against the former president.
She is now trying to open up an on going case
to add more, Jeremy, of trump's words in the
CNN town hall defaming her into that.
Do you think she'll be success NFL.
>> As a matter of law, there's a determination
by that verdict that his words were malicious
and defamatory and he doubled down and continued
that.
Let me take that back.
It's amending that on going complaint that
already started from 2000 -- from the previous
complaint.
And it establishes and confirms that the president
was willing to be malicious, knew it was and
it wasn't just his opinion, he was really
using some of the same words that he was found
liable for almost moments ago.
>> I have a question about recent polling
Errol, to you.
The numbers have gone up.
Even after the --
>> For trump.
>> Even after the liability, the $5 million
that he is to pay, according to the judge,
E. Jean Carroll.
You're seeing these numbers trend up.
Why is that?
>> Yeah.
One part of it, very core thing you have to
keep in mind, is
[7:14:35 AM]
you have to keep in mind, is that most people
are not paying attention to these things.
So in whatever capacity Donald Trump's name
gets mention and gets national exposure, it
reminds people, he used to be our president,
I kind of liked him, I might vote for him,
you'll see those things play themselves out.
Does it necessarily mean that people look
at him favorably and think that this means
that he should be president because he just
lost another case or has been indicted criminally
in new York City?
I don't think so.
>> I couldn't help this, I get a lot of sort
of solicitation for money from all the parties
because -- as a reporter gone --
>> Right.
>> So what you see sometimes is these cases
being used as, look, they're coming after
me, please give, 5, 10, 25.
It's being used as a fundraising tool.
>> It is.
I use the term funny but that's really not
appropriate.
The argument has always been the deep state
is after me.
Look, they're coming after me.
But, what the deep state, it's a
[7:15:36 AM]
But, what the deep state, it's a state of
mind and his words getting him deeper and
deeper in trouble.
Ultimately this is going to catch up to him.
He's got Georgia, the city of New York.
Now he has the federal probe that's been on
going.
Just one on top of the other.
The more he does this, and the more he uses
his words without his counsel and evidently
even with his counsel the more he will find
himself in deeper trouble legally.
I would not be shocked ultimately if he does
end up incarcerated, which is something I
would not have thought months O ago or --
>> Why do you think it now?
>> So many different things that developing
that are really significant crimes.
You're taking documents and materials that
are confidential and using them to your advantage
or concealing them.
There's an on going investigation.
You knowingly taking steps to prevent the
government from retrieving that property.
That just sort of furthers the -- my belief
and I think many people, though as I always
say, the people or the government have to
prove their case beyond a reasonable doubt
that there is something amiss here.
[7:16:37 AM]
here.
It's continuation and continuation of trouble
that he's getting himself into with his words
that are contradictory and his actions that
arguably speak for himself.
If you recall in the federal matter the judge
said on its face there's criminality.
That's a lower standard.
>> You have to continue -- it's a lower standard.
>> To continue the probe.
>> Correct, correct.
Allowing the piercing of that privilege because
the crime fraud exception.
There's something here.
Can't just say where there's smoke there's
fire, but it's